بطل عليكم كل يوم في صباح العربيه لمده
ساعتين لكن خلف الساعتين عمل على مدار
الساعه سندخلكم الان في كواليس صباح
العربيه كيف تصنع الحلقه من الفكره الاولى
الى لحظه البث الاولى نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صباح العربي البرنامج الصباحي الاضخم في
الوطن العربي يطرح مواضيع مختلفه بطريقه
مبتكره تجاره قنبله نوويه صغيره
ولكن من هو الفريق وراء صباح العربي نتعرف
عليهم من خلف الكواليس
الحكايه تبدا من هذه الغرفه حيث تصنع
الافكار تطرح في الاجتماع ونتفق على خطه
سير المواضيع واحيانا لا نتفق
[موسيقى]
وهنا ينقسم الفريق الى فريق المحتوى وفريق
الانتاج ونبدا بالكتابه والانتاج والتواصل
والبحث عن الضيوف
وفي تمام الساعه الخامسه بتوقيت جرينتش
يبدا البث وتبدا اللحظه التي يعمل عليها
الفريق على مدار ال 24 ساعه
[تصفيق]
ونكمل العمل
نودعكم هنا لكننا مستمرون وسنكون على
الموعد دائما
يعني سنه احنا سنه احنا اخر ما ننظف صباح
العربيه بس في ذكريات حلوه ذكريات جميله
ودائما كمان بدي اقول للمشاهدين وراء
الكواليس انه بلاحظ دائما انا واياك انا
وسهام عندنا بعد كل بعد كل حلقه اشياء
نحكي فيها ونضل نضحك فعلا بعرف انها بعد
اكثر في هالسنه لانه كنا عشر
يعني احنا بلشنا مع بعض بس مع كل مع كل
مرور السنين ما صح لنا انه نتقرب من بعض
وهي فرصه انه كمان تقربنا من بعض وكثير
احنا في تفاهم وحب بيننا فعلا وكمان تحيه
كبيره نادين للفريق فريق صباح العربيه
بالكواليس كلهم كلهم واحد واحد وانا كمان
يعني بما انه على هالسيره اسمحي لي انه بس
كمان نشكر كلهم بالاسم بدنا نحكي كمان
مدير الفريق مشرف الفريق وسام ومنتجه
البرنامج اشواق كمان راح نشكر لميس على
عبد السلام عمر خلود ضفاف ايهم وهبه وكل
المصورين وايضا سبيل المخرج جمال والمخرج
رب ى وكل العاملين ايضا في غرفه التحكم
واحنا بنكون مباشره من الاحد الى الخميس
كل الحب لكم جميعا